[Musique]
seydou camara les quais williams dans la
série je peux même présenté franck si
vous voulez
[Rires]
des réalisateurs et acteurs les plus
bankable de ces dernières j'ai trop
merci messieurs dames est aussi dj ce
nom
[Musique]
on va être fort c'était incroyable c'est
au delà de tout ce qu'on pouvait espérer
puis on a vécu ça dans une période
tellement particulière vivent ça pendant
le confinement la seule chose qu'on
valide pas c'est qu'on n'a pas pu fêter
tout ça avec les gens
j'en ai une je me suis dit
j'aurais bien aimé voir cette idée c'est
un mec qui nous a dit mais en fait tout
ça n'est qu'un coup marketing la vidéo
instinct est une vidéo qu'il a fabriqués
et en fait rien ne s'est passé c'est
juste un coup marketing et franchement
c'est un internaute qui a twitté ça j'ai
tellement trouvé l'idée champ mais
qu'avant même moi on m'a fait réfléchir
de tien est ce que je changerai pas
bon on a mieux
les crises personnage alors je le valide
et puis je valide aussi la participation
de saïd taghmaoui qui répétons-le en
france depuis longtemps pour la petite
histoire le premier jour de tournage de
saïd c'est aussi le premier jour de
tournage de la série la saison 2 est
donc ça a permis d'apporter tout de
suite la rigueur de la discipline cette
saison pour la narration du personnage
de nasser je trouve que les ramène à une
dimension beaucoup plus sombre dans la
saison 2 et on parle de sujets vraiment
qu'ils sont qui sont malheureusement
récurrent dans la vraie vie donc je
trouve que c'est chercher
on avait plein de trucs à raconter à
marseille et marseille c'est vraiment
une ville hip hop quoi et avec tellement
de talent la bac c'était déjà douloureux
pour moi de par leur père à marseille
tourner pour la première saison peut pas
passer à côté de marseille si on parle
d'europe
à travers les menaces de carrelage sur
ma star ça permet de traiter de la la
déchéance du d'un rappeur seth se poser
la question qu'est ce qui se passe dans
le rap quand ça marche mais parce que
c'est aussi ça une carrière artistique
il ya des moments de gloire est calé
moment que ça marche moins c'est
l'ascension d'un d'un mec qui a été
notre plus gros problème en saison une
et de le voir un peu plus d'un an après
face à à des jeunes qui ont vraiment
faim de base était de la même équipe
[Musique]
moi je valide une saison 3 que si je
suis sûr qu'elle va être mortelle et que
j'ai des supers choses à raconter